[Music]
hello and welcome to our session goodbye
expensive Legacy databases hello
next-gen postgres database
my name is Sandy guy product manager for
lodb for postgres I'm joined today by
Yuki Makino CTO of played a fast-growing
Japanese company that delivers real-time
customer insights via their platform
karda
here at Google we're seeing a rapid
acceleration of customers migrate their
databases to the cloud but as they make
that Journey many are rethinking the
technologies that they use
our customers want to modernize from
Legacy proprietary services and
standardize on open source
and there's one database in particular
that we're seeing customers standardize
on those grass
that's because it's open source it has
the portability that's becoming
increasingly critical for Enterprises
and a license free cost model
it has a rich functionality that can
compete with commercials Tech and grade
Technologies
not to mention a broad ecosystem of
extensions
it's used by millions of users
supporting Mission critical applications
in almost every industry
and of course it has an awesome friendly
community
so if you're struggling to eliminate
your dependency on high cost proprietary
database engines and are looking to
standardize on open apis like postgres
you've come to the right place
today we're going to chat about alloy
DBA a new postgres compatible database
service for commercial grade workloads
designed to help free you from expensive
unfriendly licenses and vendor lock-in
alloy DB launched a preview this may and
we're so lucky today to be joined by one
of our preview customers Yuki Makino
from played to hear about his real world
experience with some of alloy DB's most
exciting features
next we'll demo our latest launch alloy
DB support for database migration
service
and finally what's next for Alloy DB
today we're excited to announce some new
features and chat about the momentum
we're seeing with customers and partners
so let's get started with alloy today
postgres has become a popular migration
Target for legacy proprietary databases
but re-platforming to open source was
historically difficult because some
commercial grade capabilities were still
lagging at gcp we've typically seen that
the most pressing pain points are in
these first three areas
scale performance unavailability
we also see opportunities to address
postgres specific management challenges
from postgres vacuum or Reclamation of
storage to Resource Management like out
of disk and out of memory errors and as
customers look to get more from their
data on gcp we want to enable new use
cases around real-time operational
insights and AIML
and that's why we built the remote to be
a new open source compatible database
ready for top tier relational database
workflows it combines full postgres
compatibility with Google native
infrastructure for better performance
better scale and better availability
alloy DB is available today in preview
in our performance tests lodb is four
times faster than standard postgres per
transactional workloads powered by a
Google native storage service designed
and optimized for postgres
and it's up to a hundred times faster
for analytical queries thanks to alloy
DB's columnar execution engine which
leverages columnar technology for faster
scans joins and aggregations
that boost not only makes queries faster
but opens up the ability to do more
real-time analysis directly on the
database
and the columnar engine is so easy to
use you get significantly fast queries
with no schema or application changes
needed and we can even automatically
populate the columnar store using
machine learning to understand your
workload patterns
of course the heart of any managed
database service is reliability
lodb customers can expect higher
Regional availability out of the box
backed by a
99.99 availability SLA
inclusive of maintenance
I'm so excited to be able to offer this
customer friendly SLA to give our users
more peace in mind thanks to some unique
capabilities
alloy DB automatically detects and
recovers from most database failures
within 60 seconds independent of
database size and load
it's supported by a multi-zone
architecture with zero RPO for in region
failover
and finally our architecture also
supports non-disruptive instance
resizing and database maintenance
that means that your ring maintenance
the primary instance can resume normal
operations in seconds while read replica
pool updates are transparent to this
lodb is highly scalable with horizontal
scaling of read connections up to a
thousand vcpus and linear write
scalability
our storage service backed by proven
Google native infrastructure offers
horizontal scale out of database
optimized storage
and finally it's easy to manage with
autopilot systems like automatic vacuum
and memory management
automatic storage tiering across
multiple layers and formats of cache
excellent out of the box performance and
price performance on a variety of
workloads
of course alloy DB is fully postgres
compatible with a broad supported list
of flags and extensions
that allows you to move your existing
apps as is with no code changes and
leveraging existing tools like PG admin
or operational processes like PG dump
and PG Restore for import export
and finally we offer predictable and
transparent pricing no license fees no
Iowa charges you get great price
performance for your workload and
storage is pay as you go
that means you're no longer provisioning
disk you just write to the database and
build storage goes up drop a table and
you'll see build storage go right back
down
and now let's hear from Yuki about his
early experiences with alloy DB at Play
startup company before enjoying it right
I work for IBM in rme drive and mainly
work for distributed Data Systems
including in memory distributed TV or a
programming language processor and a
text analyst engine today I quickly talk
about the highlight of our redb use case
foreign
provide a sales platform for customer
experience the name is called it manages
customers experiences or on on the web
to know the real-time state of its
customer and to approve the action for
them
it has not only a wide variety of
analytics functionality to understand
the customer experience but for
supporting interaction on the web it
also analyzes user state every time for
every single user with strong
consistency and also it calculates
upgrade actions within one second in
that transaction
in order to realize htap R square we
originally made up the app with a
purpose system with CCB components and
they support our massive scale data
processing
our system handles more than 100
000 transactions per second and each
other more than 10 petabyte data 300
such such as scale data we use bigquery
big table and spanner heavily in the
back end
now rodb has been added to the gcp
family
since that we can extend the range of
data analysis and it utilization
already we can fill the gap between
large large scale databases on gcp
compared to spanner and bigtable rdb can
answer flexible analytic query
it flexible because it allows you to
process queries without schema change
additional databases require some
expertise to create indexes and optimal
schema tuning for analytical query
performance
already we can answer analytical query
with row relationship
already we use a built-in memory engine
and responds with grow latency when the
target data can be located on its memory
of course rodb is one of scalable
databases and rodb can be scaled up for
right and scaled out for read if the
size of your data isn't set about scale
the range of its utilization is greatly
expanded
however for our use case we cannot
ingest all of our large scale data to
rodb in order to bring out the character
characteristics of rdb we are defining
an appropriate subset of our large-scale
data to ingest the Rockets data in
memory for creating a new analytics
application
by properly combining these gcp
databases with rdb we can expand the
possibility of data analysis more
the benefits I mentioned in the last
slide are provided by its emulate
current engine
when cheaply measured and evaluated the
performance with our actual data and
typical queries and tested our workload
with and without indexes
we looked at three types of queries
simple count calculating on average and
unit count
performed up to about 100 times faster
with a faster than wizard the column
engine was also up to about 10 times
faster than an index scan
already we can expand the possibility of
data analytics analytics and utilization
and simplified systems with minimal
investment for htap or scale
it enables us to analyze much data
flexibly with relationship
combining together as a gcp products we
can solve a wide range of problems in
the real world by using petabyte scale
data thanks
thank you so much Yuki it's really
awesome to see the culmonary engine help
you deliver real-time insights to your
customers
so as you can see we're very excited
about alloy DB and want to make it as
easy as possible for you to get there
last month we announced the previous
database migration service support for
Alloy DB
to make homogeneous migrations from
postgres easier than ever
database migration service makes
migrating simpler more secure and more
reliable
and now over to Shahar for a quick demo
hi my name is and I'm the product
manager for the database migration
service today I'm going to show you a
quick migration between possible SQL to
alodb for possible SQL if you ever use
the MS2 micro process SQL databases this
will look incredibly familiar as rdb
exposure compatible migration steps are
identical
let's see it in DMs
now let's walk through the DMS
experience
you can access DMS from the Google Cloud
console navigation under databases let's
find it and click database migration and
migration shop
to get started you create a migration
job which represents the end-to-end
process of moving your data from source
to the Target first let's add more
details to the migration job like Name
ID source and Destination type in our
use case it's possible SQL to lodb for
postgres
the migration will be continuous meaning
DMS will migrate the database with
minimal downtime or disruption to the
application
based on my selection DMS displays the
pre-configuration required for
successful migration on the source
and that are required to achieve
connectivity
The Next Step would be to Define my
source database
I can do this by defining a new
connection profile which represents how
DMS connects to my source these profiles
aren't locked to individual migration
and can be reused
I've already created a connection
profile for my password SQL database
running on Google Cloud engine so I'll
select it
now that has my connection profile I'm
ready to create a brand new alloy DB
cluster to use it for my migration
if you ever used or created an lodb for
postgres cluster this will look
extremely familiar you'll see many of
the same options like machine
configuration on connectivity
I'll make my selections and create a
cluster we'll start by adding the
cluster ID
password
networking method
and would configure my primary instance
ID
and the Machine type that I would like
to choose to my cluster to my ldb
cluster
now I'm ready to define the connectivity
between the source database to the newly
created allodb cluster
since my source is already running on
Google Cloud I'll choose the VPC
pre-ring
thank you
and then choose the VPC I want to
connect to
I've configured my source created an
lodb cluster and established
connectivity the last step is to verify
that all my configuration are correct
install the migration job
my migration job validation is currently
running and I would like for it to be
completed
now that my migration job passed
successfully I can trust that my
migration would run smoothly I can
choose to create my migration and study
it later or create and start it
immediately I create and start the job
immediately
once my migration job is started I can
monitor its progress in the migration
jobs Details page
DMS will first transfer the initial dump
of the data and then continuously
replicate changes as they happen since
DMS is serverless I never need to worry
about scaling the migration resources
that's it now that my migration job is
in CDC and replication phase I can
choose to promote the migration job this
will stop the replication from the
source to download DB cluster
and then I can configure my application
to write to the brand new allodb for
possible SQL cluster and the migration
will be completed it's that easy
that's it I migrated my password SQL
database to a brand new rdb for postgres
in a simple secure and serverless way
thanks Shahar we're already excited
about the early momentum in postgres
migrations
for customers like sensodyta DMS can
help them migrate multiple terabytes of
data to alloy DB and take advantage of
massive performance improvements over
350 percent in their case with no
application changes
customers coming from Oracle we've also
announced Oracle to postgres migrations
available in preview
so what's next for Alloy DB
today we're announcing some awesome new
features including support for cross
region replication which we'll be
rolling out to preview
alloy DB will provide asynchronous
replication between regions for disaster
recovery and geodistributed local reads
another big feature we recently launched
is customer managed encryption Keys
allowing you to use your own Keys
managing KMS for encryption
and that's just the beginning
since our preview launched last May
we've delivered features across our
investment areas with launches and
improvements in availability data
Protection security and compliance and
developer experience and will continue
to do so
we're also seeing amazing momentum from
our customers in preview from fast
growing startups like played to
Enterprises like Deutsche Bank and
PayPal customers are already seeing how
alloy DB can be a part of their future
and finally we're seeing momentum with
our partners we've already built up an
ecosystem of Partners like Infosys HCL
and pythian we've tested alloy DB
extensively and already have deep
expertise to help customers with
implementations
these Partners have experienced
migration from postgres implementations
book on premise and in other clouds as
well as with heterogeneous migrations
from other databases such as Oracle
and finally alloy DB integrates with
leading Technology Solutions like
confluent stream bigvisor datadog
calipra and more
getting started is super easy just visit
cloud.google.com allo DB
thank you so much for listening in and a
special thank you to Yuki for joining me
today
enjoy the rest of your next 22.
thank you